I've always been very sure of myself
even when I was wrong you know what I
mean is that that makes sense like I
have a two-year-old woman and he's
like I have a two-year-old toddler son
who's got that same characteristic where
he's always very sure of himself even
when he's completely wrong so you do a
4.5 GPA will you to 4.2 GPA no I was
like of the 3.5 okay because I just
didn't care got it and that was 3.5
without trying at all when you're
playing sports were you an athlete
cheerleader cheerleader okay big high
school or small High School 2 000 people
graduated in my high school so
relatively big more English less math
did you like science hated Math and
Science okay I loved English
communication so kind of makes sense and
I'm doing a notification and when I
graduated I majored in journalism in
English so words always just came very
easily to me I loved to read